welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
today is Professor Ava's Amana a
professor of history and international
and area studies and director of the
Iranian studies initiative at the
Macmillan Center professor amma knots
teaching and research interests include
modern Iran and the Middle East
she ISM and apocalypticism he has
written several publications including
pivot of the universe and resurrection
and renewal professor Amina is with us
today to talk about his newest book
apocalyptic Islam and Iranian Shiism
welcome professor on the knot thank you
so much I'm glad to be here in your
newest book you explore the history of
Shi Islam what is she Islam well she
Islam is really a historical phenomenon
in terms of its long duration over the
course of Islamic history starting from
the very beginning of Islam based on
some kind of a religious or belief
disagreement in early centuries of Islam
and then gradually developing into
distinct communities from Sunni Islam
particularly from 16th century became
more of a religion of a state in the
case of Iran which is the largest Shi
community in the world with but perhaps
70 million or 60 odd million of the
population also there are communities of
she's in other parts of the Middle East
and Beyond including in southern Iraq
which is the majority of population of
Iraq in southern Lebanon when also there
is a large community in Pakistan in
northern Arabian Peninsula you would see
variety of community
of she's she's and therefore can be
defined both in terms of community and
in terms of beliefs in terms of beliefs
are something which is characteristic of
schism
is this kind of a preoccupation with a
sense of suffering over a course of time
a kind of a story of suffering which is
very much symbolized by the sacred
figures of early Islam and it's also a
history of expectation for some
messianic return and in that regard
indeed she has much in common with other
religious traditions virtually all
religious traditions one might say which
all have an element of mechanism but
more specifically with Christianity and
the idea of the Jesus second coming with
Judaism and the idea of the return of
the Messiah and indeed with
Zoroastrianism the indigenous religion
of Iran where she is played a very
important part in all these traditions
there is this sense of idea of a return
or return of a heroic saintly prophetic
figure sometimes at the end of the time
and it's kind of an closely associated
with the notion of Apocalypse in all
these religions and schism also inherits
or indeed influenced much by all of
these traditions as major similarities
in many ways with Christianity but also
with the other of religious traditions
this is another characteristic important
characteristic of schism
okay so what's the premise of your book
well the the book tends to emphasize
that this messianic apocalyptic aspect
and she's that endured over fourteen
hundred years
has sometimes been overlooked in favor
of him or what might call normative
mainstream Orthodox form of schism which
like stone Islam or like other religions
is very much institutionalized it's
based on the part of the clergy it's
based on a certain set of belief systems
this kind of alternative way of looking
at religion this way of looking at
religion is kind of a desire for a
messianic return has often been less
studied and the purpose of the book
therefore is to try to show over a
course of time how this has developed
how this tendency has developed within
Islam and more specifically within
schism
a couple of chapters of my new book
actually tends to look at it both within
a comparative framework with comparison
to other religions and within Islam
itself and then try to look at its
development over the course of time both
in medieval in early modern times and of
course a big chunk of it in modern times
that is mostly 19th and 20th centuries
ok so what drew you to this topic did he
did it evolve out of your other research
or something else both actually
as you have mentioned in the
introduction I have been working and
reading and writing and teaching aspects
of Iranian history Middle Eastern
history and Islamic history of which the
notion of these kind of movements of
change movements of reform and movements
of revolutionary movements within Islam
many of them with a Shiite component
played a very important part and as such
there has been a kind of a lifetime
interest in the subject and indeed this
book develop
as a result of some studies that I had
done in forms of articles or various
chapters that I had written before and
now I have put them together with some
new material in order to and to my great
surprise to see that they have such a
coherence in the form of a kind of a
single narrative that runs throughout
throughout the book the second point
about it is that contemporary Iran I was
surprised to see that some of the themes
that I have been preoccupied with has a
new life in a sense particularly under
the present president of Iran this kind
of a anticipation for the return of a
messianic figure the math he was going
to bring change into the world and so
forth is very strong and indeed the last
chapter of the book is a extensive study
of various manifestations of the idea of
the return of the idea of this kind of a
messianic manifestation in today's Iran
so let's talk a little bit about the
research you needed to do for the book
well the research was in part based on
textual material in pre-modern times
focusing mostly on the writings of the
many of the figures of this kind of
messianic inspiration many of the trends
in schism that led eventually to the
emergence of new religious forms or even
new religions such as for instance the
famous Bobby Baha'i religion that I
indeed there is a chapter in this book
about how it initially was transformed
from the kind of a body of Shi messianic
ideas into a new religious belief and
then of course in more modern times I
deal
on variety of other sources some of it
newspapers travel accounts histories
personal narratives perhaps less of
archival work because this is a kind of
a topic that does not lend itself well
to archival studies much of what I have
studied this in this book indeed was an
undercurrent which were most of the time
was either not seen easily by The
Outsiders by the people observers and
mostly it's an attempt to try to read
against the grain of what the historical
text would tell you so what is
apocalypticism and how has it influenced
the development of modern GI theology as
I was saying apocalypticism in a very
broad sense of course it has a very
specific Christian biblical meaning in
the sense of its association with the
Book of Apocalypse of Revelation but the
term itself in a kind of a technical
sense means something broader than that
means is an aspiration for a for a an
end to your notion of present time to
the human society's notion of present
time sometimes it's very violent as it's
often the term associates with the kind
of a catastrophic cataclysmic event
let's say in Hollywood movies and
sometimes it is more specifically in a
symbolic way defined as a kind of a
symbolic shift in time
therefore the end of an era an end of an
epoch and the beginning of a new epoch
is what it's indeed desired by this
collective change usually the
apocalyptic change is a component of a
messianic return you have a charismatic
prophetic saintly figure which has been
expected has been promised for a long
time who emerges appears in a bodily
human form and indeed in many ways it
reflects the aspirations of the society
in which he comes from or she comes from
and then it brings about usually in a
dramatic way usually even by declaring
that the end of the time has arrived and
the beginning of a new time a kind of a
utopic view a utopian view of the world
in which the realm of justice and equity
has to be benefited by the entire human
race sometimes very specific societies
communities sometimes web in a broader
sense and in a sense there is a there is
an idealism associated with it sometimes
it's very religious as indeed
apocalypticism often implies in terms of
the religions that I have named
sometimes it could be purely secular we
can see in the writings of many
historians
I'm sorry many religious figures and
some literary works even in poetry we
can see some this apocalyptic
aspirations as I said a little cinema we
can find that phenomenon so it's
something that seems to have been very
deeply engrained with human nature to
try to see a moment of shift from one
pattern of life to another okay so what
doing the research did you find most
surprising well and perhaps the most
surprising for me was the emergence
basically of
these ideas which to us as historians or
scholars seem to be purely a historical
phenomenon that you would not expect in
a modern or rather postmodern societies
of today to remarriage and I was very
surprised to see in a sense despite all
years of following these trends in
today's Iran to try to see that they are
reemerging not only with most recent
episode but indeed you can see look at
the Iranian Islamic Revolution of 1979
as I have argued in my book as indeed a
very much a messianic phenomenon with
Ayatollah Khomeini the leader of the
Revolution is really kind of most
prophetic figure that in many ways
manifests or reflects this kind of a
characteristic of a messianic figure and
then of course later on in a more
explicit way in the recent past five six
years under President Ahmadinejad so the
fact that you can see indeed a present
updated version of the emergence of
these themes in today's Shiism or
today's Islam as a matter of fact was
was a surprise to me and in a sense
confirmation of what I have been saying
in my other work earlier on so do you
have a sense of why that is happening
sure as I was pointing out apocalyptic
or messianic aspirations is a very
complex phenomenon and it can be
attributed in part to the fact that we
are at the end of the third decade of an
Islamic Revolution speaking specifically
in the case of Iran and there is a sense
of disillusionment with what the
revolution had promised and never
provided there was
this creates enthusiasm in the early
years of the revolution the years of the
first decade basically under Ayatollah
Khomeini himself that he would bring an
ideal Islamic society into this world
then there was a very traumatic period
of eight years of war with Iraq which in
a sense by itself was very apocalyptic
in its nature like the first world war
which many historians would indeed claim
as spite that created the sense of
disillusionment the sense of end the
sense of total break from the norms of
the society and in this case of the
iran-iraq war we can find the same
phenomenon and then after that for about
10-15 years a a promise for the
emergence of a more open society
particularly on the president heart I
mean there was this great promise that
the Islamic Revolution is eventually
kind going to be to accept the world
outside and try to come to terms with
the war the more reformist vision of
revolution and that also failed in a
sense or never really managed to
transform the Iranian society and
therefore the third phase is what we are
witnessing today which tends to promise
going back again to the expectations for
a better society expectations for coming
of a figure that is going to bring about
change and eventually materialize what
has been promised so one can in a few
words can in nutshell can regard this as
a as a reflection of the trauma of
disillusionment of the Islamic
Revolution fascinating thank you very
much for being here with us today and
sharing some
your work thank you for more information
about Professor Amana and his newest
book please visit our website at Yale
edu backslash Macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you